hey Bob Bob have you seen my charger Bob
hi I'm mark also known as markiplier I
hope none of your neighbors hear this
cuz I'm practically shouting my name and
everyone's gonna come burst in the door
it's probably fine but I am not home I'm
still in Bob's apartment he's [ __ ]
sick of me right Bob he's really peeved
that he has to keep coming to the
airport to pick me up but I can't help
it
because Delta keeps canceling my flights
over and over again so I've been stuck
in DC for two more days and I'm still
gonna be sleeping over here one more
night and leaving early in the morning
to go back to Los Angeles so tomorrow I
don't have videos for it but as soon as
I get back I'm gonna play no man sky but
until then I'm stuck here doing nothing
yay well I mean I was not doing nothing
we've been hanging out it's been fun a
little bit you can't see but he's
nodding his head definitely agree about
out fun it's better that is [ __ ] let
me start over this is all [ __ ] hi
I'm mark welcome back you didn't go
anywhere [ __ ] god damn it
oh hi my name is markiplier I am a
youtuber so I'm gonna be back in LA very
soon it's just not here yet I did not
plan to be here two extra days so
obviously I didn't record videos for two
extra days and also I'm missing no man's
sky which is a really cool game I
watched Bob played as soon as I get back
to be doing videos on it and it'll be
super cool and there's a whole bunch of
other videos that are gonna be underway
but I can't do that because I'm here in
this lovely apartment
it's a [ __ ] I guess that's all I
have to say then so what can you do our
other so yeah I'll be back when I can
thank you everybody for being patient
thank you for everybody who made free
markiplier trend on Twitter for a brief
period of time while I was in the
airport but yeah I'll be I'll be back
soon it'll be great I promise maybe
unless it gets cancelled again cuz holy
[ __ ] I wouldn't be surprised by I'll
assemble something out of that
[ __ ] also to be clear he's not
being an ass it's not that he's calling
this apartment that I live in a [ __ ]
you have to quitter I also think it's a
[ __ ] watch it you said it I was like
there's gonna be people who are like
holy [ __ ] I know your flight got
canceled but why it's I think it's a
[ __ ] - this is like a temporary
apartment we leave in three days so [ __ ]
this apartment yeah not mark everyone
but mark yeah so I'm not an [ __ ]
get it I'm just a victim